peter how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself i am
doing fantastic i'm super excited to
talk to you when i told people that you
were coming on i got inundated with
questions
and uh and all kinds of things to talk
about so maybe first let's just start
with the russia ukraine conflict i think
is kind of the the event that everyone
is focused on at the moment oh there's a
war i hadn't noticed
when when you think about that what is
your analysis in terms of like how do we
get here and is it specifically related
to just the nato kind of expansion and
what's i think been talked about a lot
in the mainstream media or are there
other elements that led to this event
that maybe people aren't as aware of or
paying attention to
this was always inevitable uh in any
world where the united states
is no longer banning war and is no
longer regulating commerce in the way
that we did during the cold war in the
post-cold war period uh the russians
were always going to go out and try to
resecure what they see as the gateway
invasion access corridors uh places like
the polish plains the best arabian gap
uh the baltic sea they were always going
to try to do this uh what has changed
is that the russians are literally dying
out and the post cold war generation
that was born through the 1990s was so
small that the russians were losing the
capacity to field a regular army so if
they didn't do it now they would lose
the possibility and there they would be
then unanchored in this kind of great
open flat zone in the middle of eurasia
and the next time there's a war they
couldn't stop it so they're hoping to
forward position what they've got left
in these gaps and ukraine unfortunately
is between them and two of the most
important gaps so it's not just that
they're going for ukraine they're going
for modova they're going for parts of
romania and poland and all of estonia
and latvia and lithuania it's just a
question of timing uh but ukraine is
the flavor of the month
uh
i kind of see this war as the last
conflict of the cold war because as long
as the russians existed
and
their security was going to drive their
decision-making so it's kind of like how
the civil war was the final war of the
american revolution we're kind of at the
end of this section of history now
when you think about what's happening uh
kind of on the ground and of course i i
always am careful to say like we don't
really know what's happening because we
can just go off of the reports that
we're getting uh it seems like uh russia
may have thought that they would uh be
able to be successful in ukraine much
quicker than they have been so i think
they've been a little surprised by the
resistance that they faced and also it
appears that uh they may have thought
that china or other countries were going
to have much more support for them than
it appears that they do is that a fair
characterization in terms of maybe some
assumptions that russia had going into
it and they've been surprised by the
lack of success or support that they've
received
absolutely one of the things we've seen
in a lot of the authoritarian
governments that are existence right now
most notably russia and china is that
their leadership has completely isolated
themselves from the rest of the world
and so if you are not
if you are in putin's inner circle you
don't dare give him bad news because he
will kill you so there were a lot of
assumptions that were made in the
kremlin that just have turned out to not
be true now in all due defense to putin
and the kremlin everyone in the west was
thinking the same way
we never thought that the europeans
would pull together in the way that they
did we never thought that we would get
any sort of meaningful international
sanctions that included countries like
japan and korea we thought that the
ukrainians would crumble we thought that
the war would be over in a month you
know everyone has gotten it wrong but
from my point of view the single
biggest flaw
is the complete collapse installation
institutionally of the russian military
they are making mistakes that were worse
than what the iraqis did in 1992 or what
they themselves did during the chechen
wars just that the inability of them to
launch any sort of meaningful
multi-domain operation and what we
thought of as the second most advanced
military in the world is just
blows your mind
and forces the russians now to do siege
mentality tactics where they just
obliterate civilian infrastructure
because now that's the only way they can
win the war
when you start to think about
the participation of nato allies in this
conflict there still is no no-fly zone
there still is uh at least officially no
troops on the ground from those nato
allies uh but there seems to be quite a
bit of flowing of both capital uh and
weaponry to ukrainian forces uh how is
that helping would they not be able to
provide this resistance without that
and i guess kind of how important is it
that the european countries came
together
along with the united states to provide
the support to ukraine
well i don't have a good answer for you
for how the europeans came together
because no one even in europe
anticipated this level of support and
everyone is taking any weapon system
that they can that doesn't require a
static footprint uh like uh so no jets
because that requires an airport uh or
an airfield but anything that can be
carried or moved by truck uh that is not
nailed down is being shipped in
and the reason originally was they
wanted to give the ukrainians a fighting
chance
but i think it was the convoy that was
north of kiev the 40 mile long one that
terrified western leaders
because we hear we have this 40 mile
convoy with thousands of vehicles that
stalled out in a day because of lack of
fuel just horrible logistics and then
two days later they ran out of food and
so all the soldiers had to get out and
walk back to belarus just leaving their
vehicles behind
well you know from a certain point of
view that's a yay the russians are
incompetent but until you realize that
if there ever was a direct conflict
between western and especially american
forces and russian forces on the
battlefield the russians would be
obliterated
that's a bad thing because it means that
if russia pushes through and captures
all of ukraine and moves to its next
stages which are those gaps in romania
and poland for example there will be a
direct flight fight and the russians
would be obliterated
and they would then face a simple choice
do we go into a humiliating strategic
withdrawal from which this country will
never recover or do we up the ante to
include nukes
and so once that
decision once that issue kind of sank in
in the white house in dod now we are
almost desperate to send any possible
weapon systems that we can so in april
this war is going to be incredibly
bloody because when the war started
the ukrainians only had a few hundred
uh javelin anti-tank launchers and they
only had a few dozen stinger
anti-aircraft missiles
well
that was before the americans started
supplying things in bulk they're only
now starting to arrive so we're talking
about the uh the russians suffering tank
and air attrition at an order of
magnitude higher than they are right now
and this is gone from an issue well we
need to slow the russians and extract a
cost but we know we can't win to a
if we don't win we are really risking a
nuclear conflict we have to do
everything we can short of regular
direct intervention to crush the entire
russian system as quickly as possible so
ukraine is now the field upon which this
will all be determined hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time